sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich wünsche
Ihnen allen einen schönen Tag die
Sitzung ist
eröffnet interfraktionell ist vereinbart
worden die Tagesordnung um die in der
zusatzpunkteliste aufgeführten Punkte zu
erweitern von der Frist für den Beginn
der Beratung soll soweit erforderlich
abgewichen werden die
Tagesordnungspunkte 16 und 22 werden
abgesetzt an der Stelle von
Tagesordnungspunkt 22 wird
Tagesordnungspunkt 33 Buchstabe a
aufgerufen Tagesordnungspunkt 19 wird in
verbundener Beratung mit
Tagesordnungspunkt 21 aufgerufen die
weiteren Änderungen und Ergänzungen
sowie den geänderten Ablauf der Beratung
im Übrigen können Sie der
zusatzpunkteliste
entnehmen ich mache schließlich auf
nachträgliche Ausschussüberweisung im
Anhang der zusatzpunkteliste
aufmerksam außerdem weise ich darauf hin
dass die Fraktion der CDU CSU ihre
ursprüngliche für heute verlangte
aktuelle Stunde zum Thema Migration
zurückgezogen hat sie verlangt nun mehr
eine Aktuelle Stunde am morgigen
Donnerstag zum Thema Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts z
Nachtragshaushalt
2021 die von der Fraktion DIE LINKE
verlangte aktuelle Stunde zum Thema 49 €
Ticket wird deshalb schon heute
aufgerufen ich sehe sie sind damit
einverstanden ich sehe keinen
Widerspruch dann ist das so beschlossen
ich rufe nun auf den Tagesordnungspunkt
1 Befragung der Bundesregierung die
Bundesregierung hat mitgeteilt dass
heute der Bundeskanzler Herr Olaf Scholz
zur Verfügung steht Herr Bundeskanzler
sie haben das Wort für ihre einleitenden
Ausführung frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich will
zunächst einmal zu sprechen kommen auf
das Urteil dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht heute
gesprochen hat es hat verkündet dass das
nachtragshaushaltsgesetz aus 2021 mit
der Verfassung nicht vereinbar ist das
ist eine Entscheidung die die
Bundesregierung und sicherlich auch der
Haushaltsgesetzgeber beachten wird und
wo wir jetzt
genau ja die wir beachten werden und woh
wir jetzt genau prüfen welche Auswirkung
das im Einzelnen hat eine solche Prüfung
ist auch angemessen denn wenn man viele
der dabei auch mitgesagten Erwägungen
genau betrachtet kann es so sein dass
das SE eine sehr tiefgreifende
Veränderung der haushaltspraxis der
Länder in Deutschland aber auch des
Bundes zur Folge hat und da da gebietet
sich kein Schnellschuss sondern eine
sorgfältige Prüfung ich habe
gesprochen ich habe gesprochen mit den
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der
Regierungskoalition über die Frage wie
wir mit den laufenden Haushaltsberatung
weiter vorgehen wollen das ist ja
natürlich eine Sache des Parlaments
insofern hat die Regierung da auch
keinen Hinweis zu geben aber aus diesen
Gesprächen kann ich Ihnen mitteilen dass
gemeinsam das Verständnis besteht dass
die Haushaltsberatung auch fortgesetzt
werden können was bereinigungssetzung
und beschlusslagung betrifft allerdings
hat natürlich das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgericht unmittelbare
Konsequenzen für den Klima und
transformationsfond wo die 60 Milliarden
die dort 21 eingestellt worden sind
jetzt nicht mehr zur Verfügung stehen
deshalb wird über den Wirtschaftsplan
neu zu reden sein und der muss neu
aufgestellt werden und damit das gut
funktionieren kann ist es die Absicht
oder hat der Bundesfinanzminister
entsprechend seiner Aufgabe entschieden
für künftige weitere Verpflichtung eine
Sperre zu verhängen außer unmittelbarer
Maßnahmen die sich etwa mit
dem Fragen des der Emissionen
beschäftigen von Gebäuden und ähnlichem
insofern ist das etwas was
eine gute Praxis sein kann und wo dann
die genügende Zeit besteht eine
sorgfältige Entscheidung zu treffen
welche Mittel für zur Verfügung stehen
aus dem Klima und transformationsfond
sass die Arbeit des Landes der Regierung
auch weitergehen kann meine Damen und
Herren wir haben jetzt eine ganz
besondere Situation in der wir
zusammenkommen ich will auf drei
Entscheidungen und erwegung der letzten
Woche zurückkommen die auch für unsere
Beratung heute und wahrscheinlich auch
für Ihre Fragen ebenfalls wichtig sein
werden mit den 16 Ländern ist Anfang der
letzten Woche eine Verständigung über
ein gemeinsames Vorgehen im Hinblick auf
die irreguläre Migration gelungen das
ist jetzt die dritte sehr umfass eine
Entscheidung die wir getroffen haben
seit dem frühah bei der Zusammenkunft
des Kanzlers mit den Regierungschefs und
derchefin und Chefs der Länder der
entsprechenden zusammenkunf im Sommer
und jetzt darunter ist auch eine
Verständigung zu gelungen über die Frage
einer dauerhaften Finanzierung
wechselnder Zahlen von Flüchtlingen s
dass wir wenn die Zahl der Flüchtlinge
zunimmt mehr Geld als Bund den Ländern
und Gemeinden zur Verfügung stellen wenn
sie zurückgehen das auch entsprechend
wieder reduzieren vor allem ist aber
eine erhebliche Verbesserung des
Managements des im Umgang mit der
irregulären Migration und auch der
Gesetzgebung vereinbart worden die jetzt
Stück für Stück umgesetzt wird teilweise
sind die Beratung im Deutschen Bundestag
dazu auch schon im Gange das ist ein
großer Schritt gewesen dass das jetzt
gelungen ist und wird auch dazu führen
dass unsere gemeinsame Verantwortung gut
wahrgenommen werden kann die zweite
Verständigung die auch mit den Ländern
an dieser Stelle gelungen ist ist über
die Frage des Deutschland Paktes Tempo
gelungen wo wir 100 Einzelmaßnahmen
vereinbart haben die dazu beitragen
sollen das Planungs und
Genehmigungsverfahren in Deutschland
schneller von statten gehen dass die
Wirtschaft besser wachsen kann weil es
nicht so lange dauert bis Genehmigung
und Planung abgeschlossen sind und das
ist glaube ich ein großer Fortschritt
ich will gern sagen dass wir vorhaben
diesem ersten großen deutschlandpk Tempo
weitere Maßnahmen folgen zu lassen etwa
im Bereich der Datennutzung und der
Digitalisierung des Gesundheitswesens im
Bereich der pharmafor oder der
Wasserstoffwirtschaft und die dritte
Botschaft aus Dingen die zusammengeführt
worden sind in der letzten Woche ist der
Vorschlag den die Bundesregierung
gemacht hat im Hinblick auf Verbilligung
der Belastung der Stromlieferung für
große Stromverbraucher des
produzierenden Gewerbes wir haben
vorgeschlagen alle politischen Kosten
die mit diesem Stromlieferung verbunden
sind zu reduzieren indem wir
insbesondere die Stromsteuer für das
produzierende Unternehmen auf das
europarechtliche Minimum reduzieren
indem wir fortsetzen die Möglichkeiten
die sich für besonders herausgeforderte
Unternehmen mit der
strompreiskompensation und dem Supercap
verbinden und indem wir das sogar noch
ausbauen mit Möglichkeiten die sich uns
jetzt gezeigt haben das ist ein guter
Schritt drei Maßnahmen die dazu
beitragen dass Deutschland besser
funktioniert
letzte Thema dass ich ansprechen will
werrend wir hier beraten und uns diese
Dinge umtreiben gibt es unverändert den
furchtbaren Angriffskrieg Russlands
gegen die Ukraine und ich will hier noch
einmal versichern Deutschlands
Solidarität mit der Ukraine und unsere
Unterstützung für die Ukraine sich
selbst verteidigen zu können ist
ungebrochen und wir haben fest
vorgenommen dass wir das auch fortsetzen
werden wir sind heute nach den USA der
stetigste und umfangsreichste
Unterstützer der Ukraine und das wollen
und werden wir auch
fortsetzen und wir sind auch
herausgefordert weil die Hamas Israel
angegriffen hat weil es einen brutalen
furchtbaren Angriff gegeben hat auf
Kinder auf ältere auf Zivilisten in
Israel auf feiernde Jugendliche
barbarisch mit unglaublich furchtbaren
Taten Entführung von Geiseln in das in
nach Gaza und des des will ich an dieser
Stelle auch festhalten es ist die
Politik der Bundesregierung dass wir an
der Seite Israels stehen es hat jedes
Recht sich selbst zu
verteidigen und natürlich ist es unsere
Aufgabe alles dafür zu tun dass in der
Region der Konflikt nicht eskaliert dass
die iranischen Proxis in liedanon in
Syrien Irak in Jemen nicht sich in
diesem Krieg einbeziehen und dass auch
der Iran sich nicht herausgefordert und
aufgefordert führt hier aggressiv zu
handeln wir warnen alle das ist etwas
was nicht akzeptiert werden kann es darf
keine Ausweitung dieses Krieges geben
und deshalb ist das für uns ein
wichtiger Teil unserer Politik in der
wir mit allen sprechen in der Region
genauso wie es Aufgabe von uns ist dafür
Sorge zu tragen dass humanitäre Hilfe
nach Gaza gelangen kann alles gehört
zusammen zu unserer
Politik
sie sehen große Fragen die uns
miteinander bewegen deshalb freue ich
mich sehr auf Ihre Fragen frau
Präsidentin ich bin fertig mit meinem
Eingangsstatement vielen Dank Herr
Bundeskanzler wir beginnen jetzt mit der
Befragung und ich möchte sowohl die
Abgeordneten als auch Sie Herr
Bundeskanzler darauf hinweisen dass
bitte die Zeiten eingehalten werden
damit möglichst viele Abgeordnete auch
zu ihrem Recht kommen eine Frage zu
stellen und zuerst stellt die Frage aus
der CDU und CSU Fraktion dr Matthias
Middelberg Herr Bundeskanzler das ist ja
heute wirklich eine historische
Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgericht erstmals dass
ein Haushalt des Bundes für
verfassungswidrig und auch für nichtig
erklärt wurde das hat es in der
Geschichte dieser Republik noch nicht
gegeben ich äh würde sie fragen wenn sie
sich dran erinnern können wer ist der
Erfinder dieser Konstruktion dieses
Nachtragshaushalt wer hat diese
Konstruktion diese verfassungswidrige
Konstruktion zur Umgehung der
Schuldenbremse
entworfen das will ich Ihnen gerne sagen
wir haben das sorgfältig beraten was wir
tun können wir haben uns um eine
verfassungsgemäße Lösung bemüht und die
auch miteinander diskutiert schon
während der Beratung zur
Regierungsbildung und dann natürlich
auch im Zusammenhang mit der Aufstellung
des entsprechenden Nachtragshaushaltes
es sind viele rechtliche Fragen erörtert
worden und alle waren bis jetzt der
Überzeugung dass das auch ein
ordentliches korrektes Vorgehen ist ich
finde es ist gut dass wir eine
Verfassungsordnung haben in der das
Bundesverfassungsgericht spricht und ich
bin auch sehr stolz darauf dass wir die
Urteile auch dann beachten wenn wir
vorher anderer Meinung
waren
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen Herr
Bundeskanzler sie sprachen von
wir als vor einem Jahr als vor einem
Jahr über den Eilantrag der Union
entschieden wurde in diesem Verfahren
und der abgelehnt wurde gab es eine
Presseinformation des
Bundesfinanzministers Christian Lindner
in der er sagt es sei heute eine gute
Nachricht für die vielen vielen Menschen
und es sei auch eine gute Nachricht für
den Bundeskanzler zugleich kann sich
heute der Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
bestärkt fühlen der zweite Nachtrag 2021
ist ja ein Bestandteil des
Koalitionsvertrages der zweite Nachtrag
2021 wurde konzeptionell noch
vorbereitet von Olaf Scholz als
Bundesfinanzminister können Sie uns vor
dem Hintergrund Herr Bundeskanzler
erläutern wer jetzt mit wir gemeint ist
und wie wir die Erklärung des
Bundesfinanzministers von vor einem Jahr
verstehen
dürfen das kann ich sehr gerne tun die
Erklärung des Bundesfinanzministers
entspricht den Tatsachen ich war wie Sie
sich erinnern Bundesminister der
Finanzen und habe natürlich über die
Fragen nachgedacht zusammen mit meinem
Haus was man machen kann und deshalb
haben wir gemeinsam diese Entscheidung
getroffen und stehen auch dazu dass wir
das gemeinsam getan haben jetzt handeln
wir entsprechend der Regelung die das
Bundesverfassungsgericht uns mitgeteilt
hat sie dürfen eine zweite Nachfrage
stellen vielen Dank Herr Bundeskanzler
haben Sie sich schon mit der Frage
beschäftigt in wie weit das Urteil auch
äh Auswirkungen auf den von ihnen ich
weiß nicht ersondnenen oder jedenfalls
so benannten doppelwums hat also den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond wir haben
uns vorgenommen dass wir alle Fragen
durchleuchten die sich für die
Haushaltsführung von Bund und Ländern
ergeben den WSF selbstverständlich
genauso wie viele viele andere Fragen
die sich ergeben denn es kann ja sein
dass in den erwegungsgründen des Urteils
sich viele Hinweise finden die viele der
Praktiken von Haushaltsführung der
letzten 20 30 Jahre in Frage stellen und
zwar sowohl beim Bund als auch bei den
Ländern und deshalb werden wir das genau
prüfen denn ich glaube darauf haben alle
einen Anspruch dass wir uns nicht nur
formal an das halten was jetzt konkret
entschieden worden ist sondern dass wir
auch den Wunsch und den Willen des
Bundesverfassungsgericht beachten soweit
er sich in den erwegungsgründen
wiederfindet
die nächste Frage stellt aus der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die grün Andreas
audritch sehr geehrter Herr
Bundeskanzler das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat ein Urteil
gesprochen dieses Urteil hat Gültigkeit
für uns wir respektieren das wir werden
das selbst wir werden das
selbstverständlich hier im Dechen
Bundestag berücksichtigen und umsetzen
das hatten sie gesagt daran werden auch
wir uns halten im
klimatransformationsfond werden wichtige
Dinge finanziert für die Menschen da
geht es um Gebäudesanierung da geht es
um E-Mobilität da geht es um Fragen die
Menschen im Leben betreffen die werden
auch weiterhin natürlich im Zentrum
unserer Politik stehen darüber hinaus
besteht großer Investitionsbedarf in
unserer Gesellschaft das andere ist und
da will ich nicht im Kleinen an dieser
Stelle hängen bleiben wo die Union
gefragt hat sondern im großen einmal die
Frage stellen dieses Urteil hat
natürlich Auswirkungen auch ganz
generell deswegen wäre meine Frage zum
einen wie bewerten Sie die
investitionsnotwendigkeiten und auch die
größere Wirkung dieses Urteils ganz
generell auf Politik in Bund und
Ländern Deutschland braucht viele
Investitionen wir müssen dafür sorgragen
dass wir die vielen Herausforderung für
die Modernisierung unseres Landes und
unserer Industrie auch tatsächlich
hinbekommen und das wird natürlich nur
gelingen wenn wir nicht nur auf private
Investition setzen die im Mittelpunkt
von allem stehen was tatsächlich hier zu
geschehen hat sondern eben auch das
ermöglichen mit den Dingen die wir tun
und das wird jetzt genau zu prüfen sein
wie wir den zukunftsherausforderung
weiter begegnen können und ich bin
überzeugt davon dass es der
Regierungskoalition sehr einvernehmlich
gelingen wird dort die richtigen
Vorschläge zu machen sie dann auch im
Deutschen Bundestag zu
beschließen eine Nachfrage
stellen ich würde einmal den zweiten
Teil der Frage noch mal unterstreichen
wollen nämlich die auch grundsätzlichere
Wirkung dieses Urteil die Dimension die
sich jetzt nicht nur auf den Klima und
transformationsfond beziehen könnte
sondern auch eine breitere Einbettung
hat vielleicht auch mit Blick über das
was wir im Bundestag tun hinaus auch
gesamtstaatlich als Frage die wir zu
beachten haben wie würden sie das
Bewerten ich bin
dass wir alle diese Herausforderung
bewältigen müssen ich habe über einige
gesprochen manches was wir bewegen
können ist etwas was wir durch bessere
Gesetzgebung und bessere
Verwaltungspraxis möglich machen ich
habe vorhin schon zum vom
deutschlandpakt Teil 1 gesprochen wo wir
100 Gesetze anpacken die dazu führen
dass vieles schneller und zügiger geht
und damit Wachstumsprozesse ermöglicht
werden aber gleichzeitig auch z.B die
Transformation die so wichtig ist damit
wir CO2 neutral wirtschaften können und
ein global wettbewerbsfähiger
Industrieland bleiben und das erfordert
wie gesagt Investitionen deshalb ist es
für uns wichtig dass wir bei der
Betrachtung des Urteils genau sehen wie
wir vor keiner der Herausforderung vor
die unser Land vor der unser Land steht
die Augen verschließen und dass wir sie
auch mit einem anderen Rahmen den wir
jetzt haben
hinbekommen die nächste Frage stellt aus
der AFD Fraktion Peter böringer
präidentin danke Frau Präsidentin
geehrter
Bundeskanzler das Verfassungsgericht hat
heute ein für uns nicht überraschendes
Urteil getroffen und schon den
allerersten von ihnen als Kanzler
verantworteten Haushalt 21 ja für
verfassungswidrig und sogar fürnichtig
erklärt ich verweise bezüglich der 60
Milliarden EUR zusatzverschuldung die
damals von Ihnen nachträglich 2022 für
21 durchgesetzt wurden auf unseren
Entschließungsantrag
20488 schon vom Tag der Verabschiedung
dieses Haushaltsgesetzes hier im Haus
wir haben dort nicht nur das Urteil
sondern auch alle drei begründungsteile
die heute vom Verfassungsgericht
gefunden wurden vorweggenommen nicht
weil wir eine Kristallkugel gehabt
hätten oder überragende Juristen sondern
weil die rechtliche Lage einfach
offensichtlich war an dieser Stelle und
meine einfache Frage ich versuch es noch
mal etwas anders wie der Kollege
Middelberg wie konnte es trotz aller
Warnungen und all ihre Juristen in ihren
Häusern dazu kommen dass äh
ja ihre ampelregierung die
verfassungsrechtlich zwingenden
Vorschriften der Konnexität der Notlage
mit den Maßnahmen dagegen sowie der
Jährlichkeit und der vorherigkeit
schlicht missachtet hat unsere
verfassungsrechtliche Beurteilung war
eine andere und es ist die Sache des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts sich selbst an
mein ein Urteil zu bilden ist auch zu
verkünden und wir haben das jetzt zu
beachten aber das ist jetzt nicht so
passiert dass wir entgegen unserer
eigenen Überzeugung von der rechtlichen
Richtigkeit der Maßnahme gehandelt
hätten sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
der Betroffene Klima und
transformationsfond ist ja überjährig
angelegt und schon mathematisch führt
das Urteil nun dazu dass ihm schon 2024
das Geld die Reserven ausgehen werden
meine Fraktion fände das zwar nicht so
tragisch weil in diesem Fond jaah
sowieso nur ideologisch begründete
falsche Ausgaben da drin stecken aber
frage doch noch mal kann dieser
ampelhaushalt morgen im Ausschuss und am
1 Dezember hier wie vorgestellt
verabschiedet werden ihr Finanzminister
hat das ja vor wenigen Minuten bejaht in
einer Pressekonferenz aber ich
wiederspreche auch ihrer ihrem Statement
im Eingangsstatement eben wonach es eine
Übereinkunft der Fraktion gegeben hat
die AFD Fraktion sieht nicht dass
unverändert ohne weitere Beratung und
veränderte Beratung mit anderem
Zeitansatz dieser KTF und damit der
Haushalt 24 verabschiedet werden
kann schönen Dank für die Frage ich
glaube ich habe mich genau ausgedrückt
es ging um eine Rücksprache mit den
Regierungsfraktionen und darüber habe
ich berichtet weil ich finde das
interessiert das ganze Haus zumal ist ja
jetzt sowieso bei dem
Haushaltsgesetzgeber liegt die
Entscheidung zu treffen die Regierung
kann da ja nur beraten Tätigkeit sein
und deshalb war es für mich wichtig auch
aus Respekt von dem Parlament einmal
diese Rücksprache zu nehmen sie wollte
ich allerdings davon nicht ohne Kenntnis
lassen und deshalb habe ich darüber
berichtet und das zweite ist dass ich
glaube ja es wird Anpassung geben beim
Klima und Trans informationsfond deshalb
also die Haushaltssperre und die
Ankündigung dass wir natürlich einen
neuen Wirtschaftsplan entwickeln müssen
der berücksichtig dass diese 60
Milliarden die 21 dort eingestellt
worden sind nicht mehr zur Verfügung
stehen die nächste Frage stellt aus der
SPD Fraktion Frank
Schwabe Frau präidentin Herr
Bundeskanzler die innenpolitische Lage
ist ganz gewiss herausfordernd manche
halten sie für dramatisch was wirklich
dramatisch ist ist in dertat die
außenpolitische Lage sie haben darauf
schon Bezug genommen deswegen will ich
sie aber noch mal näher fragen was tut
die Bundesregierung was tun Sie
persönlich um in der Tat eine Ausweitung
des Konfliktes rund um Israel im
nordnahen Osten zu verhindern welche
Länder sind von besonderer Bedeutung
müssen wir besonders reden und wie
schätzen Sie die Situation ein um die
Freilassung der Geiseln was kann
Deutschland an dieser Stelle
tun zunächst mal ist es wichtig dass wir
gemeinsam mit vielen Freunden warnende
Botschaften an diejenigen schicken die
gewalttätig zu werden drohen das
betrifft iranische Proxys in Syrien und
Irak hab es schon gesagt das betrifft
diejenigen im Jemen aber es geht auch
darum dass die hiszbollah sich in diesen
Krieg nicht ein mischt das sind
Botschaften die gesagt werden müssen und
von möglichst vielen und möglichst klar
und da reinen wir uns ein und versuchen
unseren Beitrag zu leisten das zweite
ist dass wir natürlich im Gespräch sind
mit den Vertretern der Regierung in der
Region sie wissen ich war in Ägypten ich
habe mit dem König von Jordanien
gesprochen mit dem Emir von Qatar dem
Präsidenten der Vereinigten Arabischen
Emirate ich werde auch ich habe auch
telefoniert mit Präsident Erdogan und
werde ihn wie Sie wissen am Freitag
treffen und da werden wir wie immer über
die Dinge reden die da zu besprechen
sind auch über unterschiedliche
Ansichten auch das ist in dieser Frage
ganz wichtig dass da Klarheit herrscht
und man sich sehr
deutlich seine eigene Position auch
vorbringt und im Übrigen geht es
natürlich in vielen dieser Gespräche
auch darum dafür zu sorgen dass
humanitäre Hilfe nach Gaza gelangen kann
dass es möglich ist dass foreign
nationals den Gaza verlassen können dass
wir es ermöglichen dass schwerkranke in
Krankenhäuser außerhalb gasas verlegt
werden können könen und dass die Geiseln
bedingungslos freigelassen werden auch
das muss ein Ziel sein all dieser
Gespräche und wir bemühen
uns sie dürfen eine Nachfrage
stellen ich will genau an der letzten
Stelle bei den letzten Sätzen noch mal
nachfragen wir haben
ja wir sind aus vielerlei Gründen aus
inhlichen Gründen aus Gründen der
historischen Verantwortung ganz klar an
der Seite Israels und dennoch haben wir
natürlich auch in diesem Land große
sorgnisse wir haben große Teile der
Bevölkerung die nicht Hetze betreiben
die aber trotzdem in Sorge sind zum Teil
um Freunde um Verwandte in Gaza auf
beiden Seiten und deswegen will ich will
ich noch mal nachfragen was kann denn
Deutschland eigentlich tun inwi weit
kann man darüber reden was wir tun
können um in der Tat auch gerade die
Geiseln die auch eine deutsche
Nationalität haben zu unterstützen
freiubekommen und wie konkret in der Tat
muss und kann die Hilfe für die Menschen
die jetzt auch in Gaza leiden in den
nächsten Stunden und Wochen sein bitte
auf die Zeit achten ja schönen Dank die
aber ich kann nur einmal wiederholen was
Druck auf Hamas betrifft muss der auch
ausgeübt werden von denjenigen die
Gesprächskontakte dain haben das
geschieht auch und wir jedenfalls sind
im Gespräch mit den Beteiligten um zu
versuchen dass eine freileistung der
Geisel möglich wird wir sind auch mit
der israelischen Regierung darüber immer
in intensivem Kontakt und natürlich
kümmern wir uns auch um die deutschen
Geiseln speziell auch wenn unsere ist
alle Geiseln müssen freigelassen werden
bedingungslos
und im Hinblick auf humanitäre Hilfe
haben wir die Europäische Union haben
auch andere welche bereitgestellt und
wir bemühen uns sehr im Gespräch z.B mit
der ägyptischen Regierung im Gespräch
mit der israelischen Regierung in
Gespräch mit den Vereinten Nationen
diese humanitäre Hilfe auch nach Gaza
gelangen zu lassen das ist schon jetzt
so dass ein großer Teil der Hilfe
übrigens für Gaza von den G7 Staaten
finanziert wird und gerade der
humanitären und das ist glaube ich ein
auch eine wichtige
Botschaft nächste Frage stellt aus der
Fraktion DIE LINKE
karenlei vielen Dank Herr Bundeskanzler
sie sind angetreten als Kanzler für
bezahlbares Wohnen Z Jahre sind ins Land
gezogen und sie haben nicht geliefert
die Mieten explodieren in diesem Land in
den Großstädten wie Berlin ein Plus von
27% in einem Jahr aber auch in kleineren
Städten wie Delmenhorst ein Plus von 13
% in nur einem Jahr noch nie war das
Wohnen in diesem Land so teuer wie zu
ihrer Amtszeit und sie haben im
Wahlkampf einen mietenstopp versprochen
und ihre Fraktion der SPD Fraktion hat
das im Sommer noch mal presseirksam
wiederholt aber hier im Bundestag ist
noch keiner dieser Vorschläge angekommen
ihr Justizminister blockiert eine
mietrechtsnovelle und deswegen möchte
ich Sie fragen wann sprechen Sie hier
endlich an Machtwort wann wird endlich
eine mietrechtsnovelle kommen wann
werden sie endlich in der mietenpolitik
liefern schönen Dank für Ihre Frage ich
möchte mir jetzt die billige
retourkotsche ersparen zu sagen dass die
Preise Mietpreise in der in den Berlin
so hochgehen lag daran dass bis zuletzt
die Partei DIE LINKE so lang viel
Einfluss in der Regierung hatte aber ich
will doch immerhin den Hinweis Wagen
dass man gegen zu teure Mieten nur etwas
tun kann indem man genügend Wohnung baut
deshalb haben wir zusätzliche deshalb
haben wir zusätzliche deshalb haben wir
zusätzliche Mittel für den geförderten
Wohnungsbau bereitgestellt insgesamt 18
Milliarden Euro und bemühen uns jetzt
dass überall Projekte in Deutschland
entwickelt werden die dazu führen dass
mehr geförderter bezahlbarer Wohnraum
entsteht denn das ist ja auch eine
Analyse die en sind es nicht ja sie sind
gestiegen und auch plötzlich aber sie
sind gestiegen auf ein Niveau das im
langjährigen Vergleich nicht besonders
hoch ist wir hatten viel mehr
Wohnungsbau bei viel höheren Zinsen als
es heute der Fall ist und deshalb ist es
so wichtig dass wir die Voraussetzung
für mehr Wohnungsbau schaffen das
geschieht mit all den Maßnahmen auch des
beschleunigungspakets über das ich
gesprochen habe und der
bundesbauministerin was das Mietrecht
betrifft kann ich Ihnen nicht zustimmen
nein es wird nicht blockiert und der
Bundes Minister der Justiz arbeitet an
den entsprechenden gesetzeswürfen und
Sie werden den Bundestag bald
erreichen sie dürfen eine Nachfrage
stellen ich erspare mir und ihnen die
billige returkutsche dass du immer dort
wo die Linke regiert hat sie ja die
Regierende Bürgermeisterin gestellt
haben sondern ich möchte doch lieber den
Blick auf ihre Amtszeit richten sie
waren als Bundesfinanzminister zuständig
für den Bundes Bau für die Beemer und
sie sind es jetzt auch als Bundeskanzler
zu ihrer Amtszeit hat die beema unterm
Strich gar nicht gebaut im vorletzten
Jahr hat die Beamer sechs Wohnungen neu
gebaut und im letzten Jahr 76 Wohnungen
gebaut finden Sie nicht dass das eine
wirklich peinliche und lächerliche
Bilanz ist und meine Frage an Sie ist
wann kommt der bundesbau endlich in die
Gänge und wann werden sie die Kommunen
in die Lage versetzen endlich mehr in
öffentlichen und bezahlbaren Wohnraum zu
investieren ich will die Frage sehr
genau beantworten und dann doch noch mal
sagen da wo ich Bürgermeister war sind
seit dem Beginn meiner Amtszeit
mittlerweile 100.000 Wohnungen genehmigt
worden und das hat sehr wohl eine
Auswirkung auf den Wohnungsmarkt und ist
eine große Leistung gewesen die von der
Partei DIE LINKE immer wieder vertretene
Thesen neue Wohnung muss man nicht bauen
es reicht Mietrecht zu regeln die habe
ich noch nie geteilt ich bin für ein
strenges soziales Mietrecht aber ich bin
dagegen dass man die mathematische
Illusion verfucht dass es mit ohne
zusätzlichen Wohnungsbau geht und dass
man sich als
Kommunalpolitikerin darum drücken kann
sein Nachbarn zu erklären dass in der
Nachbarschaft neue Wohnung gebaut werden
müssen wir brauchen wahrscheinlich in
Deutschland 20 neue Stadtteile die
gebaut werden das wird nicht alles mit
Nachverdichtung gehen auch das ist eine
Ideologie die leider viel zu verbreitet
ist was die Frage betrifft der beer Ken
jetzt nicht mehr beantworten
gut nächste Frage stellt aus der
Fraktion der FDP Konstantin
Kuhle frau Präsidentin Herr
Bundeskanzler in der vergangenen Woche
hat ja die Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
stattgefunden und die dort vereinben her
KLE warten Sie
mal Konstantin KLE hat jetzt das Wort
ich bitte
um Ruhe im Saal damit auch die Frage
gehört werden kann
so die Zeit beginnt noch mal von vorne
Herr Kuhle in der vergangenen Woche hat
ja die Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
stattgefunden mit einigen Beschlüssen
zur Migrationspolitik sie selber Herr
Bundeskanzler haben die Beschlüsse als
historischen Moment beschrieben weil sie
geeignet sind mehr Ordnung und Kontrolle
in der Migrationspolitik zu erreichen zu
den Maßnahmen gehört auch ein Gesetz das
den Deutschen Bundestag bald erreichen
wird nämlich das Gesetz zur Verbesserung
der Rückführung es ist jetzt Sache des
Bundestages dieses Gesetz zu beraten und
zu beschließen aber aus ihren Gesprächen
mit den Ministerpräsidenten was sind die
Erwartungen der Länder was sind die
Erwartungen der Kommunen wie schnell
muss das Gesetz zur Verbesserung der
Rückführung jetzt ins Bundesgesetzblatt
kommen so schnell wie möglich und ich
habe natürlich als Regierung dem
Bundestag keine Hinweise zu geben in
Bezug auf Gesetzgebungsverfahren aber
wenn Sie das dies Jahr noch schaffen
wäre das eine tolle Sache und ich glaube
das ist auch möglich deshalb diese klare
Antwort auf ihre Frage es sind
allerdings wirklich sehr weitreichende
Maßnahmen vieles davon hätte man schon
viele Jahre machen können jetzt besteht
die politische Kraft das zu beschließen
und es wird das Management im Umgang mit
irregulärer Migration erheblich
verbessern sie dürfen eine Nachfrage
stellen Herr Bundeskanzler zu den
Maßnahmen gehört eine Vereinfachung bei
den Abschiebung bei den Rückführungen
aber auch dass wir es hinbekommen müssen
Missbrauch und Fehlanreize im
Asylverfahren zu reduzieren hier möchte
ich einen Blick lenken auf das was die
Länder eigentlich tun können es ist ja
vereinbart dass bis Ende Januar ein
Konzept für Bezahlkarten vorliegen soll
es ist auch vereinbart dass die
Asylverfahren beschleunigt werden sollen
wie optimistisch sind Sie dass wir
Anfang 2024 flächendeckend in
Deutschland Bezahlkarten haben werden
und dass wir es hinbekommen werden die
Asylverfahren in den Ländern drastisch
zu beschleunigen zunächst mal habe ich
von allen 16 Ländern gehört dass sie
eine solche Bezahlkarte einführen wollen
es besteht auch der Wunsch dass das
gemeinsam geschieht mit einem
einheitlichen System damit das möglichst
unbürokratisch auch gelingen kann ich
hoffe dabei bleibt es auch sage ich als
jemand der Zeitung gelesen hat und auch
andere Äußerung von einem einzelnen
Ministerpräsidenten gehört hat aber im
Wesentlichen ist das der Wille es wird
auch nicht so schwer sein wir haben
jedenfalls von bestimmten Anbietern vom
deutschen Sparkassen und giroband aber
auch von vielen anderen gehört dass sie
in kurzer Zeit eine solche
Dienstleistung bereitstellen können
deshalb wird's wohl schnell gehen das
will ich gern dazu sagen was die
Maßnahmen der betrifft der Hinweis ja es
ist gesagt worden man will erreichen
dadurch dass die Anhörung dass die die
antragstell und Anhörung in der
Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung sind und das
Verfahren beschleunigt werden dass
innerhalb von 6 Monaten die erste
Entscheidung der Verwaltung über ein
Asylantrag erfolgt und will erreichen
dass auch die verwalfahren erst
inststanz sich beim Verwaltungsgericht
in dieser Zeit erfolgen eine wichtige
Innovation wir wissen heute gibt es ein
Verwaltungsgericht nämlich das
rheinlandfels das vier viinhalb Monate
braucht es gibt andere die brauchen 40
und ich glaube da ist Raum für
Verbesserung auch wir sind der
Auffassung
dass schonich alles nein sie haben keine
zwei Nachfragen sie müssen sich leider
setzen jetzt stellt die nächste Frage
aus der CDU CSU Fraktion Dorothe
B frau Präsidentin Herr
Bundeskanzler Deutschland ist leider
eine Hochburg sexuellen Missbrauchs und
sexueller Ausbeutung geworden und sie
sind Bundeskanzler des Landes das als
das Bordell Europas gilt schätzungsweise
250.000 vornehmlich Frauen sind hier in
einem System gefangen von
Zwangsprostitution unter sehr Menschen
unwürdigen Bedingungen sie werden von
Zuhältern in dieses System gezwungen und
Sie müssen sich ja besonders gut
auskennen mit der Thematik weil sie ja
eben schon von ihrer Zeit als
Bürgermeister in Hamburg gesprochen
haben wo das ganze natürlich auch eine
sehr große Hochburg ist wir als Union
wollen diese furchtbaren Zustände
stoppen wir sprechen uns daher für ein
sexkaufverbot aus und ich stelle Ihnen
die Frage setzen Sie sich auch für ein
sexkaufverbot ein wie beispielsweise
auch aus ihren Reihen ihre Kollegin Leni
breimeier und helfen dass Frauen vor der
Ausbeutung in der Prostitution gerettet
werden
können schönen Dank für Ihre Frage und
das ich ganz uneingeschränkt sagen
schönen Dank auch für ihr Engagement in
dieser Sache denn in der Tat das ist
furchtbar was wir wissen prostitution
ist schlimm und diejenigen die in diesem
Bereich tätig sind haben ein schweres
Leben und ganz oft ist es mit Missbrauch
auch mit Gewalttaten und mit kriminellen
Strukturen verbunden deshalb müssen wir
alles dafür tun das zurückzudrängen die
Frage wie man das am besten macht muss
und diskutiert werden und wird ja auch
im Bundestag diskutiert in einer großen
Bandbreite auch in innerhalb der
verschiedenen Parteien und das will ich
auch gerne respektieren aber ich will
ihn sagen wir müssen in der Tat sehr
viel unternehmen um Prostitution
zurückzudräen und den sexkauf wie sie
das gesagt haben nicht als eine
Normalität zu akzeptieren sondern als
etwas das nicht in Ordnung
ist sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
vielen Dank auch dass sie wesentlich
weiter sind als die
bundesfrauenministerin da freue ich mich
sehr weil die nämlich in der letzten
Woche noch in der regierungsbefragung
abgelehnt hat jetzt Maßnahmen zu
ergreifen sie will noch mal zwei Jahre
zuwarten sie haben bei Amtsantritt in
einer in der Zeitschrift Emma sich als
feminist bezeichnet und wir stellen
einfach immer mehr fest dass die Grünen
gerade beim Thema Frauenrechte und vor
allem beim Thema Prostitution die echten
Antifeministen sind deswegen danke ich
Ihnen frag sie noch mal ganz konkret
finden Sie es als feminist akzeptabel
wenn Männer Frauenkörper kaufen können
auch noch in den nächsten zwei Jahren
bis eine neue Evaluation vorliegt
zunächst mal finde ich es nicht
akzeptabel wenn Männer Frauen kaufen das
ist etwas was mich moralisch immer
empört hat und deshalb ist es auch
richtig dass hier in der Gesetzgebung
geguckt wird wie man das am besten
hinbekommt das zurückzudrängen ich habe
schon darauf hingewiesen dass es sehr
unterschiedliche Positionen dazu gibt
aber dass sie doch alle mit großem Ernst
dieser Frage folgen und ansonsten kann
ich Ihnen nicht beipflichten es ist
keine antifemin
Position die ich bei der
bundesfrauenministerin entdeckt habe und
es ist auch nicht so dass es ihr
irgendwie egal wäre sondern das ist ihr
ein Herzensanliegen gegen den Kauf von
Frauen durch von Männern die Sex haben
wollen
vorzugehen die zweite Nachfrage stellt
Dr Henstedt vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
Herr Bundeskanzler eine besonders
schreckliche Form der sexuellen
Ausbeutung ist der Kindesmissbrauch
ausweislich der Zahlen des des
kriminalamtes sind in
2021 über 39 000 Kinder äh in dem in
Film und in Videos und in Fotos
vergewaltigt und missbraucht worden
ein Instrument die Dunkelziffer ist
natürlich noch viel höher aber ein
Instrument diesen Straftaten besser her
werden zu können wäre das Speichern von
IP-Adressen ihr Chef des
Bundeskanzleramtes der gerade hinter
ihnen sitzt hat in seiner
regierungsbefragung am 8 Februar diesen
Jahres erklärt das Kabinett werde
zeitnah Gesetzesentwurf einbringen um
diese ip-adressenpeicherung möglich zu
machen sie haben das noch mal in ihrer
Regierungserklärung im Sommer
entsprechend bestätigt und ich frage
mich weil ich das für ein absutens
Skandal halte dass wir immer noch drauf
warten wann endlich kommt dieser
Gesetzesentwurf schönen Dank für Ihre
Frage und schönen Dank auch für ihr
Engagement aber in der Tat wir arbeiten
daran eine gute Lösung zu finden
entsprechend der Verständigung die wir
bereits in dem Koalitionsvertrag trag
gefunden haben und ich kann Ihnen sagen
das werden wir sehr zeitnah hinbekommen
wir sind ja erst bei der Halbzeit dieser
Regierung und das ist ein Vorhaben das
mit höchster Präzision erarbeitet werden
muss weil wir ja auch umgeben sind von
lauter Entscheidung höchster Gerichte in
Deutschland und Europa und da den
richtigen Weg zu finden der dann auch
funktioniert das ist nicht ganz trivial
aber es ist eine Sache die wir sehr
sorgfältig bearbeiten und Sie können
davit rechnen dass sie hier im Bundestag
noch an einer gesetzgebungsberatung
mitdiskutieren
können die nächste Frage stellt aus der
SPD Fraktion Sebastian
Hartmann sehr geehrter Herr
Bundeskanzler sie sind in der letzten
Zeit immer wieder auf Herrn Friedrich
März zugegangen und haben die
Zusammenarbeit zum Thema Migration
angeboten und Herr März verkündete in
der
jüngsten Zeit jedoch für ihn sei der
deutschlandpakt für Migration
erledigt meine Frage daher wie bewerten
Sie diese augenscheinliche mangelnde
Kooperationsbereitschaft der Union bei
diesem so wichtigen
Thema schönen Dank für die
Frage zunächst mal freue ich mich sehr
darüber dass es gelungen ist in ja einer
sehr sorgfältigen Diskussion die wir in
ganz Deutschland geführt hab zu sehr
vielen sehr konkreten Verständigung zu
kommen die bereits im gesetzgebungs
fahren sind oder in das
Gesetzgebungsverfahren gebracht werden
zuletzt bei der Zusammenkunft der
Regierungschefin und Regierungschefs der
Länder mit mir und ich werde das auch
gerne fortsetzen und nicht nur auf
diesen Kreis bezogen sondern die
Herausforderung der irregulären
Migration ist eine wir müssen die Zahlen
reduzieren und da ist ein möglichst
großer Konsens wichtig und deshalb werde
ich auch nicht aufhören immer wieder das
Gespräch auch über die Regierung hinaus
auch mit dem Oppositionsführer zu suchen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
sehr geehrter Bundeskanzler da möchte
ich dran anknüpfen denn es ist
tatsächlich eine historische Einigung
mit den Ländern erreicht worden
Stichwort Ministerpräsident und
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und eine
Vielzahl von Gesetzgebung Unterstützung
der Kommunen Verbesserung der
Rückführung Beschleunigung von
Asylverfahren sind Stichworte und
Gesetzgebung aber auch hier hat die
Union die Zusammenarbeit verweigert noch
heute morgen im Innenausschuss sollte
eine Anhörung aus taktischen Gründen
vermieden werden um in ein
ordnungsgemäßes Gesetzgebungsverfahren
zur schnellen Umsetzung überhaupt zu
kommen in wie weit ist unter diesen
Voraussetzung überhaupt noch eine
Zusammenarbeit mit der Unionsfraktion
relevant ich bin wiederhole gerne was
ich hier aber auch öffentlich gesagt
habe ich werde immer wieder den Versuch
machen über die Regierung hinaus
Konsense zu schmieden in Fragen die
unser Land gemeinsam bewegen das muss
mich und muss auch das Parlament nicht
davon abhalten Entscheidung zu treffen
das gilt auch für die Zusammenkunft mit
den Ministerpräsident und
Ministerpräsident identen aber das
bleibt eine Aufgabe und wenn wir uns
umschauen in der Welt dann werden wir
sicherlich genau an dieser Frage noch
viel zu tun haben insofern ist da auch
nie ein Gespräch zu
Ende die nächste Frage stellt aus der
AFD Fraktion Kai
Gottschalk ja vielen Dank Frau
Präsidentin Herr Bundeskanzler sie
kommen heute nicht ohne das Thema kexweg
sie haben ja eben auf die Frage von den
Mittelberg geantwortet dass es ihre Idee
war den KTF so aufzulegen soweit kann
ich sie heute verfassungsrechtlich
attestiert als verfassungssbreecher
bezeichnen da liebt es sicher auch
anders jetzt könnten sie ja doch
einräumen dass sie dreimal mit Herrn
olearius gesprochen haben ich habe da
noch mal das entsprechende Protokoll was
ihre Fraktion verhindert hat freizugeben
hier mit falls Sie noch mal nachlesen
möchten also soweit könnten sie heute ja
mal richtig reinen Tisch machen das vor
allen Dingen auf dem Hintergrund und der
Tatsache dass ihr stabsleiter der SPD
stabsleitung zwei Laptops aus einem
verschlossenen Tresor mit rund 700.000
Mails hat verschwinden lassen sollen die
Sie wahrscheinlich da gehe ich von aus
deswegen verschwunden belasten können
also was sagen sie denn dazu weil sie
sich ja selbst mal im Ausschuss
vielleicht erinnern Sie sich daran zum
obersten chefaufklärer in komex gemacht
haben zu diesem Tatverdacht und was
empfehlen Sie denn ihren Genossen oder
haben Sie generell in der SPD ein
Problem mit Daten ins ere die sie
anscheinend schützen
sollen das ist ein Thema zu dem das
nichts Neues zu sagen gibt und ich gehe
davon aus dass der Hamburger
Untersuchungsausschuss seine Arbeit sehr
ordentlich machen wird macht er ja
bisher auch wiederholt wiederholt
beschäft sich immer mit den gleichen
Fragen da wird nichts offen
bleiben sie dürfen eine Nachfrage
stellen das kann man sicherlich so sehen
wenn die Hamburger staatsanwaltscha
gegen sie und den Herrn uliarius keine
Anklage erheben möchte aber dann in mein
schönes Bundesland nach
nordrin-westfalenmann gehen muss Herr
Strate insbesondere dort wurde ja dann
wenigstens gegen Herrn olearius
entsprechend Anklage erhoben und ein
Verfahren eröffnet auch da wollte wohl
der grüne Justizminister
dazwischengretchen weil das eine sehr
engagierte Staatsanwältin tätig ist wie
bringen sie das denn damit in Einklag
sie hab mir im Ausschuss damals
geantwortet in dem Protokoll dass sie
nichts davon wissen dass 2017 Herr
Johannes KS von der W eine Spende
entgegenenommen haben soll sie haben
aber auf der anderen Seite auch gesagt
sie nehmen die Perspektive des
zeitungslesers ein ich zitiere sie hier
wörtlich haben Sie sich denn
zwischenzeitlich mal klar oder
informiert als Betroffener ob Herr Kars
von der warbubank Spenden
entgegengenommen hat und die vielleicht
diese Entscheidung etwa 45 Millionen
Euro Steuer nach Zahlung
niederzuschlagen einfacher gemacht haben
immerin sie waren ja Bürgermeister Herr
gottchalk die Zeit ihre Fragen sind
voller Unterstellung ich bemühe mich
aber nicht sie alle zu korrigieren aber
es gibt nicht ne zu
[Applaus]
sagen vielen Dank liebe Kolleg Kollegen
nächster Fragesteller ist der Kollege
Stefan Seidler fraktionslos aber vom
SSW jetzt aber vielen Dank Herr
Präsident sehrr Bundeskanzler als
Hamburger ich davon besonderen Bezug zu
Norddeutschland und zu den Menschen im
hohen Norden haben wie kann es sein dass
Sie dass die von einer Jahrhundertflut
gebeutelten Städte Gemeinde an unserer
Ostküste vergeblich darauf warten
mussten dass Sie oder ein Mitglied ihres
Kabinetts vor Ort waren um sich vor Ort
eine Lage oder ein Bild von der Lage
dort zu machen nach der Sturmflut
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage ich glaube
dass das wirklich eine große
Herausforderung ist dass den beiden
Küsten da stattgefunden hab auch mit den
Ministerpräsident und und den
Ministerpräsidenten gesprochen und wir
haben beim letzten Zusammenkunft über
der ich eben schon geredet habe mit den
Ländern verabredet dass wir gemeinsam
eine Begutachtung der schadenssituation
und der Handlungsfähigkeit
Handlungsnotwendigkeiten vornehmen weil
wir so ähnlich wie das bei der von Ihnen
auch im Bezug genommenen Flut im arteil
der Fall ist alles dafür tun wollen dass
hier Deutschland solidarisch den
Betroffenen beiseite
steht vielen Dank Kolle se eine
Nachfrage bitte viele Menschen an der
Ostküste sind um ihre Existenz bedroht
sowohl privat als auch beruflich wie
schnell kann dort mit Hilfe vom Bund
gerechnet werden und erlauben Sie mir
eine weitere Nachfrage es wird auch das
öfterin der Ruf laut nach einer
verpflichtenden
Elementarschadenversicherung das
Kabinett hat dies bislang abgeneigt oder
abgelehnt überlegen Sie sich in Ihrem
Kabinett Alternativen alternative
Versicherungsformen für die Menschen an
den Küsten solche ja ereign
wie Sturmfluten oder insgesamt
klimaereignisse werden uns wohl in der
Zukunft das öfteren ereilen und
dementsprechend warten die Leute dort
auf
Versicherungsmöglichkeiten ja schönen
Dank auch für diese Frage zunächst mal
ist es ganz wichtig dass hier Hilfe
organisiert wird wir haben mit den
Ländern sind wir immer in einem solchen
Verhältnis dass dort wo konkrete
praktische Unterstützung notwendig ist
sie auch gewährleistet wird das was aber
vor allem jetzt wichtig ist es zu gucken
welche Schäden sind gewissermaßen zu
reparieren und kann man das gemeinsam
tun zu dem Vorgehen in dieser Sache habe
ich eben schon was gesagt was die von
Ihnen angesprochene verpflichtende
elementalversicherung auch für solche
Katastrophenschäden betrifft gibt es
einen sehr sorgfältigen Beratungsprozess
zwischen Bund und Ländern auch mit sehr
vielen Anhörungen die Angelegenheit ist
nicht trivial um ihn etwas zu sagen
würde man das machen würde das in jedem
Fall dazu führen dass alle Hausbesitzer
und Hausbesitzer höhere Beiträge zahlen
müssten und auch alle mieterinen und
Mieter und zwar unmittelbar für Sie
ausrechenbar da geht's nicht um 1 2 €
sondern um ganz substantielle Beträge
deshalb muss man das sorgfältig machen
und eine Frage die in diesem ExpertInnen
und Expertenkreis auch gerade erörtert
wird ist die braucht es das ist ja die
Idee einer
staatsfernlösung so dass nicht immer
dann der Steuerzahler wenn eine
Flutkatastrophe oder ein andere kommt
einspringen muss für bestimmte
Schäden kriegt man die überhaupt hin
weil es gibt auch Auskünfte aus der
Versicherungsbranche dass sie das nur
machen wenn hinter ihrer
versicherungszusage noch mal der Staat
steht so dass es dann doch wieder die
Steuerzahlerin und Steuerzahler sind und
das muss man natürlich sorgfältig
verstehen vielen Dank Herr Bundeskanzler
nächste fragestterin ist die Kolleg
Bruer die
Grünen ja vielen Dank Herr Präsident seh
geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler am Freitag
auf der bundeswehrtagung hat die nicht
nur von mir sehr hochgeschätzte Kollegin
Strack Zimmermann ihn die Frage gestellt
ob die Bundesregierung eine nachhaltige
Strategie zur Unterstützung der Ukraine
hat sie haben darauf sehr knapp
geantwortet ja haben wir soweit so gut
aber klug wie sie sind wird es sie jetzt
nicht überraschen dass nicht nur wir
beiden Frauen sondern auch sehr viele
Abgeordnete hier im Parlament gerne
hören würden wie dieser Plan denn
konkret aus sieht auch jenseits der
geplanten Mittelerhöhung für das Jahr
2024 schönen Dank ich will sehr
ausdrücklich sagen dass die Frage der
langfristigen Unterstützung der Ukraine
ziemlich zentral ist wenn man Putin
richtig deutet und ich glaube das ist
jetzt in diesem Fall nicht so schwer
dann hofft er natürlich darauf dass
unsere unterstützungsbereitschaft in
Deutschland in Europa in den USA
schwindet dass er einfach die Sache nur
lange genug aussetzen muss genug
Material und eigene Soldaten riskieren
und immer weiter sein Zerstörungswerk in
der Ukraine fortsetzen muss damit er am
Ende über die lange Strecke erfolgreich
sein kann und deshalb ist die eine
wichtige Botschaft vielleicht die
wichtigste die wir aus Deutschland geben
können ist wir werden die Ukraine
unterstützen solange wie das notwendig
ist darauf kann sich die Ukraine
verlassen und das will ich hier gerne
noch einmal
unterstreichen vielen Dank und dann will
ich noch
hinzufügen wir haben eine Nachfrage komm
genau
die habe ich auch und zwar bezieht sie
sich auch auf die Unterstützung der
Ukraine die EU-Kommission hat ja auf
Basis der Fortschrittsberichte letzte
Woche empfohlen beitrittsverhandlung mit
der Ukraine und Moldau aufzunehmen aus
Sicht meiner Fraktion ist es nicht nur
ein wichtiges Zeichen ein solcher
Schritt
der Solidarität und der Hoffnung sondern
auch eine geopolitische Notwendigkeit
und in unserem eigenen Interesse was
kann die Bundesregierung tun um diesen
Prozess eu-seitig zu unterstützen auch
in der anerkenn dessen dass die Ukraine
trotz des brutalen russischen
Angriffskrieges ja auch eine Reihe von
Reformen durchgeführt hat wir sind
ständig beratend für die Ukraine tätig
und sind auch Unterstützer dabei dass
die Europäische Union ihre Möglichkeiten
zur Verfügung stellt damit die Ukraine
möglichst schnell möglichst viele der
Kriterien erfüllen kann die für einen
Beitritt unverzichtbar sind denn das ist
ja von uns allen immer wieder
festgehalten worden der Beitritt muss
meritbased erfolgen er kann nicht wegen
irgendeiner geopolitischen Einschätzung
sich zutragen sondern es muss so sein
dass man alle Voraussetzungen den ganzen
europäischen Aki erfüllt und dabei
wollen wir natürlich gerne unterstützen
und hilfreich sein sind es auch wie
übrigens auch beim Wiederaufbau wir
werden nächstes Jahr die
wiederaufbaukonferenz jetzt in
Deutschland ausrichten und bereiten uns
jetzt schon aktiv darauf vor vielen Dank
nächster Fragesteller ist der Kollege
Christoph Meer FDP
Fraktion
ja danke Herr Bundeskanzler wir haben
in der letzten Woche eine ein großes
Strompaket
zur Kenntnis genommen können Sie noch
mal die Elemente darstellen und können
Sie noch mal den marktwirtschaftlichen
Impuls den sie damit für das Land im
nächsten Jahr geben hier darstellen
schönen Dank
das war ein Vorschlag den ich zusammen
mit dem Finanzminister und dem
Wirtschaftsminister gemacht habe und wo
ich den Eindruck habe dass er vom
Parlament aufgegriffen werden wird aber
das ist ja in den Händen des Hauses
jetzt hier die recht endgültige
Entscheidung zu treffen es geht darum
ich will das noch mal so erläutern die
politischen Kosten die auf dem
stromlasten für diejenigen die große
stromprverbraucher sind im
produzierenden Gewerbe wegzunehmen
deshalb also die Reduzierung der
EU-Steuer auf das äh der der Stromsteuer
auf das EU Minimum das ist für alle
Betriebe die davon profitieren eine
Entlastung auch die diejenigen die
bisher schon profitiert haben und sehr
große Entlastung hatten und einige
andere noch zusätzlich und es ist
gleichzeitig so dass wir dann die beiden
Instrumente strompreiskompensation und
Supercap fortgesetzt haben wo es ja zum
Teil auch darum geht die Kosten der CO2
Bepreisung aus der Stromproduktion
herauszunehmen für die Unternehmen die
sehr viel Strom verbrauchen und damit
entstehen zusammen mit dem Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien und billiger
Stromproduktion die Bedingung die
industriell Tätigkeit in Deutschland
wettbewerbsfähig machen ohne dass das
Subventionen werden sondern es ist
gewissermaßen eine Erleichterung in dem
der Staat auf erhebliche Einnahmen
verzichtet vielen
Dank Kollege Meer sie Nachfrage bitte ja
eine Nachfrage sie haben ja ausgeführt
dass
das produzierende Gewerbe produzierende
Unternehmen entlastet werden könnten
sich vorstellen dass gegebenenfalls auch
noch weitere Unternehmen die unter hohen
Energiekosten leiden z.B die
Textilbranche die Textilreinigung
Branche entlastet wird der Vorschlag
bezieht sich auf die produzierenden
Unternehmen wie ja übrigens auch die
bisherigen Instrumente
strompreiskompensation und Supercap die
wir ja auch noch ausbauen wie ich vorhin
erläutert habe sich vor allem an diese
Richtung an in dieser Richtung bewegen
und das hat was zu tun mit
internationalen Wettbewerb damit solche
Tätigkeiten solche Produktion solche
industrielle Tätigkeit in Deutschland
stattfindet und auch neu investiert wird
und ich glaube da sind die Maßnahmen die
wir vorgeschlagen haben hocheffizient
dass wir jetzt noch viele Ausweitung
vorschlagen können kann ich nun gerade
auch nach der heutigen Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts so richtig
nicht erkennen aber vielleicht ist ja
jemand weitsichtiger als ich vielen Dank
Bundeskanzler nächsteer Frage stell ist
der Kollege Matthias wie birgweal
Fraktion DIE LINKE vielen Dank Herr
Präsident Herr Bundeskanzler zur
Rentenpolitik mir geht es um das Problem
der doppelverbeitragung von
Betriebsrenten und von
Direktversicherungen mit
krankenversicherungs und
pflegeversicherungsbeiträgen vorgestern
haben die Betroffenen
direktversicherungsgeschädigten eine
Mahnwache vor ihrem Bundeskanzleramt
abgehalten um sie zum wiederholten Male
auf diese Ungerechtigkeit aufmerksam zu
machen und um sie an ein Versprechen zu
erinnern welches sie ihnen gegeben
hatten sie Herr Bundeskanzler hatten den
Betroffenen bei einem Bürgerdialog in
Essen am 11 September vergangenen Jahres
versichert dass sie Zitat nach einer
irgendwie fiskalischen möglichen Lösung
Zitat Ende suchen würden und am 25
Januar wiederholten sie dieses
Versprechen hier im Plenum und sagten
auf meine Frage es wird noch darüber
nachgedacht wie man das konkret
ausgestalten kann aber das ist etwas
dass wir uns vorgenommen haben und Sie
können sich drauf verlassen dass wir
auch Lösungen dafür erarbeitet haben
Zitat Ende meine Frage nun an sie sind
ja jetzt 10 Monate vergangen fast Herr
Bundeskanzler im Namen von 6 Millionen
direktversicherungsgeschädigten bitte
ich Sie höflich und ausdrücklich uns
jetzt zu sagen was sie in der Sache
ausgearbeitet haben wie ihr Sachstand
ist und vor allem wann die Betroffenen
mit einer Lösung werden rechnen können
schönen Dank für die Frage ganz klare
Aussage erstmal es sind schon eine ganze
Reihe von Maßnahmen ergriffen worden
auch in der letzten Legislaturperiode wo
ich mich sehr verwandt habe und es wird
auch weiter daran gearbeitet eine gute
Lösung zu finden wie auch einer der
Betroffenen bei einem meiner letzten
bürgerdialoge selbst formuliert hat
vermutlich nicht indem es eine
Rückzahlung von 13 Milliarden Euro gibt
denn auch da wüsste jetzt wahrscheinlich
keiner wo das genau herkommen soll aber
eine die dazu führt dass man das Gefühl
hat dass es für die Zukunft gut geregelt
ist das glaube ich ist etwas wo wir uns
schon Mühe geben müssen und die Mühe
wird sich gegeben allerdings kann ich ih
die konkreten Maßnahmen nicht vorstellen
vielen Dank Herr Bürger eine Nachfrage
bitte ja selbstverständlich also selbst
die 13 Jahren Rückzahlung fordern noch
nicht mal wir wir haben fünf andere
Vorschläge dazu später mehr ich ahnte
dass sie mir so antworten würden das
haben sie am 25 Januar hier im Plenum
ähnlich gesagt es sei bereits eine
Lösung gefunden worden dem widerspreche
ich denn der Freibetrag gilt ja nur für
die Krankenkassen bei Beiträge und nicht
für die
Pflegeversicherungsbeiträge und eine
Halbierung der Beiträge auf den
Arbeitnehmeranteil wie bei der
gesetzlichen Rente den gibt's ja auch
nicht hier geht's also um zerstörtes
Vertrauen bei den Betroffenen und die
sind überwiegend keine wählerinen und
Wähler der Linken also Herr
Bundeskanzler wie gedenken Sie dieses
verlorene Vertrauen für die Betroffenen
wiederherzustellen durch inem man sehr
ordentlich damit umgeht und keine
falschen Versprechung
macht vielen
Dank nächster Fragesteller ist der
Kollege Alexander TH CDC
Fraktion vielen Dank Herr Präsident Herr
Bundeskanzler Jüdin und Juden fühlen
sich in Deutschland nicht mehr sicher
das ist eine Schande und beschäend und
da sind wir uns sicherlich einig
Vizekanzler habik hat in einem
bemerkenswerten Video am 2.11 folgendes
gesagt das Verbrennen von israelischen
Fahnen ist eine Straftat das Preisen des
Terrors der Hamas auch wer deutsche ist
wird sich dafür vor Gericht verantworten
müssen wer kein Deutscher ist riskiert
außerdem seinen Aufenthaltsstatus wer
noch keinen aufenthalstitel hat dieefert
einen Grund abgeschoben zu werden
stimmen Sie dieser Aussage ihres
Vizekanzlers insbesondere was den
letzten Satz anbelangt zu alles sind
Auskünfte über die gegenwärtige
Rechtslage ich will das hier auch gerne
sagen dass ja der auch von mir und
vielen anderen von der ganzen
Bundesregierung immer wiederholte
Tatbestand ja auch unsere Realität ist
es ist verboten israelische fahen zu
verbren es ist verboten antisemitische
Parolen zu brüllen es ist verboten dass
man den Tod von Menschen von Juden
bejubelt und deshalb machen die
versammlungsbehörden z.B von ihren
Möglichkeiten Gebrauch und haben wegen
der wegen der Gefahr solcher
straftatenversammlung untersagt und es
wird auch von Polizei und Justiz
ermittelt wer solche Dinge tut um gegen
die entsprechenden Personen vorgehen zu
können das ist dann natürlich die
Voraussetzung um das bestehende
rechtliche Instrumentarium in dieser
Hinsicht auch auch einzusetzen gegen
konkrete
einzelne vielen Dank eine Nachfrage
bitte her Bundeskanzler ich muss ich
korrigieren das entspricht nicht der
geldten Rechtslage jedenfalls nicht was
das Aufenthaltsgesetz anbelangt ich
glaube wir sind uns einig dass
Antisemiten in unserer Gesellschaft kein
Platz hat und deswegen erwarte ich auch
eine gewisse Klarheit nicht nur vom
Vizekanzler sondern auch vom
Bundeskanzler selbst in dieser Frage
sind Sie bereit einen Gesetzentwurf
einzubringen der jedwede antisemitisch
motivierte Straftat dazu führt dass in
der Regel eine Ausweisung das heißt der
Verlust des bleiberechtes erfolgt sind
Sie damit einverstanden ich bin mit ihm
nicht einverstanden bei der Bewertung
der Rechtslage es gibt sehr umfassende
Handlungsmöglichkeiten bei
antisemitischen Straftaten und was es
vielleicht gibt es in der Vergangenheit
ein Vollzugsdefizit da bitte ich das zu
ändern und fordere alle auf das auch zu
machen vielen
Dank nächster Fragesteller ist der
Kollege BT bergt
gut wde dann eine zweite
Nachfrage na jetzt herzlichen Dank Herr
Präsident Herr bundeskanz ich wird sie
bittenen sich da noch mal entsprechend
kundig zu machen sie wollen jetzt aber
trotzdem trotz dieser Situation in
Deutschland auch der aufgeheizten
Stimmung in Deutschland das
Staatsangehörigkeitsgesetz hier durch
den Bundestag dur peitchen mit einer
einbürgung nach schon 3 oder 5 Jahren
und mit der regelhaften doppelten
Staatsbürgerschaft halten sie das
wirklich in dieser Situation und mitten
in einer migrationskrise für das
richtige Signal in unsere
Gesellschaft schönen Dank für diese
Frage ich will jetzt versuchen in der
ganz kurzen Zeit die mir zur Verfügung
steht darzu etwas zu sagen aber ich will
Sie darauf hinweisen dass das zur
Debatte im Bundestag
stehen